it's white to move and mate in two moves
and this is composed by the wonderful
pal Benko who still works raining a
chest columns every month for a chess
play so made into obviously if you were
trying to win the game you could do so
in so very many ways right you could
just play Queen takes Queen
you could play f5 check but we're
looking for a mate in two moves by force
this is a chess problem a problem means
that it was composed by scratch and of
course it's an honor of Valentine's Day
because why is it why did I show this in
Valentine's Day anything you notice
about the position yeah it's shaped like
a heart
right it's a Valentine's Day chess
problem so that's really or not only did
this composer I mean Benko I think is
amazing
not only did he have to create a maiden
- that was beautiful because otherwise
there's no real point of mating to the
point of them is that they're supposed
to be really difficult to find in a way
and also they have like some kind of
beautiful and surprising solution and
then in addition to that it had to be
shaped like a heart you already have the
answer what Tommy I think not mate
because the Queen can take right so
we're not just talking about good moves
here because we've already conceded that
if Y was just trying to win this game
there would be many many ways you could
do that we're just trying to find a
forced mate in two and that's when we do
with chess problems a lot of times it's
not about winning the game it's just
about finding the forced mate also
important for chess problems is if the
maiden - it's only considered to be a
good or a high quality chess problem if
there's only one made in - if there are
multiple mates in - then it's not
considered a good problem and those
multiple mates and two are called
anybody know what it's called when
there's an alternate solution to a
problem
hmm
no no anybody a study chest problems
before know the term Ford is a cook I
don't know where it came from actually
but it's called a cook and it cooks are
considered bad you don't want to have
cooks there should only be one way it
made into I know you know he's just
letting some other people try to get a
chance to solve it
black smooth no it's white smaller white
maiden move and made into
well yeah we already talked about how
taking the queen is just winning but
we're looking for made into because it's
a composed chess problem the difference
between a puzzle usually and a puzzle
I'm just saying well what's the best
move how do you win whereas a chess
problem there's usually a very specific
stipulation and this one is way too mean
in to know people ask does studying
chess problems make you better at chess
because usually it's unrealistic
situations like you don't normally find
yourself in a chess game and your pieces
are shaped in a heart unless you're
really trying hard to make that happen
or torture your opponent or you're
giving them a Valentine's Day you know
chess problem present but it does help
your chest because it really improves
your creativity in chess it's really
important well I last last night when I
was doing the intermediate class we were
talking about all these different
beautiful quiet moves and one of them
included a king March that was very
surprising in the middle of the board
and actually you found it so it was
pretty cool but the point is that
problems help creativity even if it's
not realistic it helps you expand your
mind so that where you're sitting there
at the board you're not just thinking
about the first thing that you look at
but you're you're thinking about weird
things and once in a while those weird
things work
nor friends in the back are probably
gonna get this because you guys are
pretty good for the advanced beginners
class mm-hmm you're both ready what
about 1700 oh that's all right so that's
good that you came in late for this
problem because yeah but don't call it
out just just in general in this class
they try to raise your hand at all times
because I expect that you might get some
things faster than the rest of the
people which is totally fighting her
here so I make sure everybody can get a
chance to solve the puzzles as well let
me just go on and review some names so
we've got Chris Sal
Tommy XIV XIV how do you spelled like ze
such a cool name is Eve Azim Oh
XIV and Azim yeah
that's not difficult Vincent okay
and I think I only must do Kevin okay
okay
it's you looking for a maken to you
that's made into Mo's exactly meet in
true moves exactly
hmm.well f5 check Queen takes pawn it's
not me so basically if you're trying to
mate in two it's got to be you move they
move checkmate right that's mated to so
you don't have a lot of room for error
hmm who asked that Oh Tom Thomas Thomas
right yes the first move is a check
which is so unusual and problems a lot
of times they like to use those quiet
moves that we talked about yesterday for
those of you who weren't at the lecture
and quiet moves it will be uploaded onto
YouTube on the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube channel which is just st. Louis
Jeff's right STL Chess Club yeah so STL
Chess Club it'll be up there no the
first one's 998 that's a good idea
though because in these problems you
really want to look at all possibilities
but if you were to play an IEE I would
just play Bishop takes d8 and then you
wouldn't have a maid in one there so you
need to have a maid in one after you
make a move you guys happen in the back
let's let's give everybody another
minute but uh if I if nobody gets in in
a minute or two off on you yeah got it
you got it okay cool
I gave it a hint what's your hand okay
hmm that's good because I thought you I
thought you might give it him though you
said think outside the box I thought you
were gonna give a hint that was like
gonna totally give it away well I'll
give you guys a hint it's a it's a check
and it's a sacrifice yeah it's at what
do you got it no quit for is not it
because if Queeny for Bishop takes Queen
and that's also at Jax huh that's not
quite right August you got it
Queen c4 is a really good idea that's
actually not right because Queen c4 is a
really good idea because if Queen takes
Queen and then what's a made in one yes
pontiff ëismí right but it's not a
meeting - because if you plead Queen C
for track I could block and then it just
wouldn't be made right you wouldn't have
that made Queen b6 yeah you should have
raised your hand because I think some
other people had it but that is good
Queen d6
is the move so if Queen takes d6 what's
an 8 mm and if Bishop takes what's the
main C no because I'm Queen takes pawn
so if we Queen b6 Bishop take six give
me a square 98 exactly so the key here
is Queen b6 a very pretty move that's
what you were thinking right okay good
so everybody was in the back Julian and
Austin oh okay all right well yeah I
mean the surprising how hard Nathan 2
can be and this is from bencoseze a book
of a book about his life by Jeremy
Solman which also has lots of great
compositions by him and it is really
astonishing you think that if you get to
a pretty strong level in chess you
wouldn't have trouble finding mates in
two but sometimes it's hard
and after mr. Titus D 698 is very pretty
made and of course if Queen d6 Queen
takes D six five so for those of you who
have girlfriends and wives who decided
not to take out on Valentine's Day you
can make it up to her by just showing
her this position when you come home so
be totally even basically right okay
good okay
exactly yeah that's one way to look at
it yeah he lost do background check me
actually when I was like already master
because I think I was playing in a
simultaneous and it's like it's the one
way it's easy to lose it at simultaneous
because you're just trying you're just
like racing around the board making
moves quickly and I had forgotten to
make love and it's like little kid just
checkmates me and he's probably like a
thousand or something and you know
making fun of me that for the rest of
the test camp it was pretty awesome all
okay got really really was not happy
about that I'm not the type of person
where if I give a sign while I'm trying
to crush every single person like I'm
also trying to play quickly but I don't
really like losing very much so this one
is just a white to move and win so this
kind of takes advantage there's like a
lot of the problem I'm gonna show you an
hour a bit variations my bag ranked me
so how do you use the idea because most
of your opponents and let's it's they're
under a lot of pressure
whether it's like my case I was playing
thirty games at once or they just have a
couple minutes left in the clock
for whatever reason most people of your
level are not gonna just fall into a
background check me for no reason
usually it's gonna be because you set it
up right that you did something clever
which caused them to forget about it or
to miss something
in this takes advantage of two themes
usually in practically speaking and
chess there are often two themes at work
in this case we're making use of the
back rank theme and we're also making
use of the pin theme yes work f8 please
uh you know use your hand because you
saw two in a row now ZZZ
but work f8 at the right answer because
then if Queen takes Queen
you've got rook takes g8 me so that's
kind of like a back rank it's like a
variation on it and now I wanted to show
you a game interesting just the mole
kind of go for the opening quickly but
this is a game from the strongest female
chess player in history Judit Polgar and
this was from an Olympiad when she was
about 12 at the time of the game so it's
a pretty impressive display of I her
anybody know what this opening is called
great yes it's called the rocks and lemo
Sicilian the Sicilian is defined when
your opponent plays four when you play
eat warn your opponent plays c5 and move
that Queens Bishop pawn forward anybody
in this room play c5 in response to e4
okay a few people in the back the rest
of you probably mostly play e5 in
response to see for Julian you mostly
play e5 and c5 you play both great and
the knight of three is the most common
response and now after an 86
the most typical response in this
position is d4 but Bishop e5 is also a
pretty good move a lot of people play
this as well so now black is feeling
kettle and out what's the point of c3
why do you think white would play c3
what do you think crest and he thought
why wait we play c3
August yes that's the reason yes but
which is a particularly effective setup
to have when your opponent's Bishop is
being cathode so e5 and out wait lady
for anyway so she decided to sacrifice
upon and we'll see you I she did that in
a minute
so I guess her idea in this position is
that the black king is a little bit open
and this is also not exactly a clean
pawn this pawn is also pin so it's a bit
tricky for black to complete all of her
development so now she did another
sacrifice by playing e5 and what do you
think would happen if black were to play
Bishop takes e5 here how would white
play here what's that if they play
Bishop a c5 we're just in general they
she's just like I'm ready to stir from
the tournament beforehand working one
okay and then if black were to play app
six somebody else you know white just
plays live yeah so obviously black can't
take on e5 so instead of likely 97 you
know why he played [ __ ] of d5 creating
another pin you know black castle my
captures on d4 now after knight c6 Queen
h4 hitting the Queen Queen to b6 Knight
c3 continuing development so you see
there's a lot of issues here with the
development it's very difficult to
develop these pieces and it's very
difficult to move this pawn forward
because if this pawn were to move
forward what would happen Chris we did
talk about this what's the problem with
moving the pawn forward to d5 well you
know a lot of the time tonight would be
able to take but there's something else
I'm gonna let Chris answer this cuz he's
like starting out it was a special rule
that we talked about at the beginning of
the class yeah
right well he can but if he does you get
to use the role right it's called a
Poisson yeah so the d5 the problem is
that the d5 is stuck in so if you can't
develop the deep one you can't develop
the Bishop and if you can't develop
[ __ ] you can't develop the rook
so lack of development is sometimes got
that like kind of domino effect and now
finally black decided to take the pawn
off and why it got another piece into
play you'll see that in a lot of
attacking players games that the key is
getting all the pieces into the game
they also call that inviting everyone to
the party again we saw that variation on
that yesterday and that famous short
two-man game where Julian found the king
of for motif so work a e1 and by the way
what is what is White's directly right
in this bit man
what's Weis thread in this position if
it were White's move its blacks move and
by the way working one is a big
sacrifice but if it were White's move in
this position what would right there
well that's what black did because black
uh-oh wait which one that's why you
should yeah what use algebraic notation
yeah what Bishop takes Knight and then
Bishop takes c6 and then after pawn
takes exactly so that tactic is called
no removing the defender yeah until it's
blacks move those so black do the same
technique herself to capture this bishop
on it unbe five so this was a sacrifice
the sacrifice began with rook a e1
because it allows me to take c3 and now
after a pawn takes c3 the bishop 1 b5 is
hanging so again remove all the guard
it's a pretty common tactic and now why
would white sacrifice a piece here what
do you think white can do in this
position this is a pretty awesome game
actually
[ __ ] makes a really good idea but if
Bishop h6 how can black reply this is
something we talked about it I think
yesterday also and maybe last week as
well your biggest goal if you're getting
attacked is to try to trade what pieces
but specifically Queens the reason is
that you you had never hear about
somebody getting into an endgame and
then just getting checkmate in the open
board it happens but it's pretty rare
normally the endgame is defined by the
fact that the king is no longer in
danger directly right that you know
obviously somebody might Queen a pawn
and then it can be in danger again
but in the endgame King safety is
usually not the big issue and that's why
a lot of times in the endgame if you're
on Castle you'll see people playing King
e7 or King d7 rather than castling right
so black would play what yeah Queen h5
seems like a good move and this kind of
ruins your idea of playing Queen to f6
because now I could take this right so
Bishop h6 and I don't mind but I don't
mind losing this because I'm still gonna
be up in material cuz you sacrifice the
piece so if you were to take and take on
f8 I'd still be ahead of material right
cuz I got the night in the [ __ ] up
first the rock and that's worth more and
in this position notice I don't have to
worry about development anymore and
that's why trade into the endgame is so
great for a player who's getting
attacked because now I am gonna have
time to play d5 and Bishop e6 and move
my work out definitely a good idea but
not the right one
what else can wait consider
you guys already got in the back kind of
you're still analyzing okay good good
you b7 you don't really want to tweet
pieces when you're talking you know like
I'll probably just take it I'll be happy
because it's bishop the key attacker it
was very strong pas and that's why the
suggestion of Bishop h6 is a really good
one
so we're trying to get in those squares
and checkmate another move that I would
certainly look at but I'd probably
reject for the same reasons would be
what what's another right try to get
into those squares and make them yeah
Bishop f6 I probably look at Bishop f6
too but also Queen h5 could could be a
concern there so anyway
any other ideas
so we've looked at different move orders
we tried Bishop f6 we've tried Bishop h6
and all times the idea is to put the
Queen there and then then get the Queen
Medusa Batman right but this Queen
coming over and threatening to trade
itself is keeps annoying us so yeah so
where where would you move the Queen
down oh you mean like place play what
yeah you could do that I think the
problem with that is that if you were to
play c4 here and then I play Queen to f5
to helped me because this Queen is is
useful here as a defender it helps
promote like f6 so the problem is it's
not like I'm gonna move the Queen
somewhere like that like out of the game
right
Queenie chicks was played yes and let's
try to figure out why so Queen Atrix was
playing and now what's weight
threatening if it's white to move in
this position what will white play an
easy one but yeah [ __ ] f6 and it's
that's forced me there's no way to stop
me right so how can black stop it where
are blacks different ways of stopping it
well take you the [ __ ] it's pretty bad
though yeah I mean you can take the
bishop and just play a few more moves
than resign yeah yeah you could resign
or die but Queen takes g5 is not
something you're really like if you see
that your opponent has to play Queen
takes g5 then you don't really need to
analyze it anymore because it's after
Queen takes g5 you've reached a logical
conclusion there's no more checks
there's no more captures in your upper
queen for two pieces so that's the point
of which you're like okay I'm gonna play
this move what about what else can black
do to stop me
besides Queen thanks best shop at stakes
good what else let's just try to think
of all the candidate moves for defending
yeah Sam
pawn that's that's what as II said also
the last six or a five yeah okay but
let's look at that first and then we'll
look at other possibilities okay so
let's say they play f6 air now what can
wait do
so
more than spawn August Bishop f6 Bishop
f6 work at six
yeah and then King s oven yeah good okay
so if you have six is mating
because if work f7 we can just go Ricky
eight question though what if we're to
try to reverse the move order because
move orders are really important concept
in chess and this position kind of
illustrates it if we were to play rook
e8 first what would black do why is that
different with the same idea that we
after work take c8 Bishop f6 and made on
g7 where is the hole in that thing
there's a couple holes actually at least
one well ok after black take the rock
and then Bishop takes off sex how can
you defend against the may you be
defended with King f7 although I still
have Queen g7 check and working you won
so it's pretty dangerous what other way
could you defend against it there's
another way if for key a rook takes e8
Bishop takes f6 in addition the plane
King f7 you could also play remember
when your opponent sacrificed a lot of
material it gives you license to Reese
AK Rifai some material for the defense
Justin you see it working it work take
c8 Bishop takes pawn and then ya
rookie 7 is a pretty good move because
you after Bishop takes the e7 Knight
takes these heaven you're actually up to
pieces alright so once you start
stacking you always have to be aware of
Rhys Accra faces or counter sacrifices
because your opponent usually has a lot
of flexibility to do that especially
when you start giving up a lot so Bishop
f6 seems to work there so instead of and
by the way the same exact variation on
f5 right just because we're not taking
up on all the variations basically stay
the same so instead what's the other way
to defend against Bishop to f6
only other way that black can stop white
from playing [ __ ] about sex
hmm pong at five is kind of the same
though because we just played with about
sex
mmm yes Queen at five exactly and now
what do I do
no yelling out where's your hand if you
get it
come on second let me give you a couple
more people a chance anybody I'll see it
so you got a really good combination
here as Wyatt you got okay good
actually I'll give you a hint it's
actually a mate in three so that's how
brutal disposition is well I can
actually mate in three moves starting
from this position
got it Oh a couple people got it August
I can see by the smiles okay well you
should know I think if you see it you
know right yeah what's that
okay go very good Queen takes rook check
King takes rock and then wat mm-hmm King
d8 excellent very good so a very
beautiful romantic move Queen takes a
faint romantic and Valentine very again
King takes off a Bishop h6 check and
again we saw that this love not being as
good as the other left of course it was
it was kind of destined to be this way
because black and fie and head on a fish
up there so it's not like she tried to
play g6 to make looked what's that
and angle Oh violet I don't I haven't
really seen her name much since then it
was a long time ago I was an 89 or only
88 of them yet so after Bishop h6 check
King can't go here because of the rook
and now when the King goes to g8 working
aids mate so very very pretty finish
there by Judah pulgar and a very classic
example of why it's important to develop
early because if you know even one of
these pieces I hadn't been out or if
this pawn had been advanced it would
have been much easier for black to
defend by simply moving a bishop at some
point to stop the meeting so exactly
playing a bishop and I look down the
whole game it's not usually a good
strategy oh good good finds guys let's
look at another example
oh and this is a very famous game but
I'm gonna take it to the I'm gonna I'm
gonna breeze through this because we
don't have time to look at the whole
game but this is a really cool game with
a capital blank I am training mode okay
this one you'll see in almost all your
tactics books that's one of the reasons
I wrote play like a girl because there
are some amazing tactics that are used
over and over again like this one is
really a cool tactic but I also find
that especially before the tactics
trainers online started to become
popular a lot of people in writing
tactics book we're recycling the same
positions and I found that unfortunate
because there are so many fresh
positions and tactics being created and
modern games like the one we just looked
at that Queen takes a fait thing and
naturally more women playing now than
ever so what generally happened when
people recycling tactics there were very
few games by women in these books the
book I wrote play like a girl has
tactics all by email just buyers so it
wouldn't have included this one that's
okay
and now black to move
yes
he's got it already once I
I'll call on you in a minute just like
even given the rest half a minute a
minute hmm you don't believe me I set
you that and then I forget and I call in
somebody else right I keep doing that
but you got a lot of them right in the
beginning in the class well if you play
Queen check my only move is queen up on
all right and then if you play if you
play rook to d1 what happens right so
there you've got an issue where both
players have weakened back ranks
got a top you got I got an idea
are you scratching
see what do you think well Queen to be
one and then queen f1 that was just
mentioned but then you missed you missed
something at the end of it remember look
at your opponent's ideas not just your
own right what you miss your back ranks
week two right so a queen bee one queen
f1 worked you on we get to play rook c8
mating
black was I really me well it's like
you're gonna win I won't say it's a mate
yeah
Queen B 2 is the correct move very good
very nice move now the idea is if Queen
takes Queen black just has just has
worked you on mate so what are whites
other options if white tries to cover
the back rank with something like Queen
e1 now what can black play someone else
better we got a lot better than that Sal
huh now we can play Queen takes rook and
if Queen takes Queen rook do you on is
mating right so the only other
possibility that we haven't really
looked at is well what if it works e2
trying to just what does it not change
well now if we play Queen takes work
though Queen takes Queen and guards to
be one square right so it changes things
a little bit
right exactly Queen B wanted now it's
different than the other position
because now when the Queen goes to ask
one instead of work t1 which will still
be to me you can simply go you can
simply take the rock all right so those
are pretty cool possession and this this
again you'll see in all tactics box very
good
right well I really like this move
because it's cool like in a way it's a
it's it looks like a flashy move because
we're attacking we're sacrificing the
Queen but it's also kind of a quiet
moving away because in the end the whole
point is that you're just gaining that
one little tempo or that one that will
note nuance that the rook is now under
under capture there's not really a
defense now I mean you can't really you
can't protect this rock and protect this
Queen and protect this checkmate it's
just an over loading situation well
they're thinking about these pawns is
generally it's a great place generally
you don't want to move your pawns in
front of your King too much because it
makes the King weak but in the case of
back ranks you can't use that principle
you can't hold on to that principle so
much because once pieces start trading
off this pawn formation actually ends up
trapping the King whereas before it was
protecting it so that's why once you see
files opening that's usually a good
moment to play something like h6 and
make yourself that error early in the
game a lot of times you want to keep
your pawns just like that
especially if it's close I mean it
really depends but sometimes you don't
want to touch them and you almost
certainly don't usually want to play
like g5 and h5 type moves leaving your
King naked alright this is another one
so this is a black to move black to move
and win and there's just a nice one too
easy for you because of what we've
looked at but it's it's interesting
because there's just a couple of
different things that might come to your
mind first
way too
well Queen III oh that's what that is
not the best move because if you play
Queen III then what can your opponent do
I think an arrow just showed it yeah hmm
well but waking me here right yeah so
always looking for your opponent's ideas
too so instead in this position you do
want to use that bang cranks distraction
idea but the Queen III is the wrong
execution instead August Queen V 1 is
the correct execution because now you're
continuing to cover all of these squares
so in a weird way you're attacking and
defending at the same time right so the
only way for white to play now if we
take on b1 there's that brutal checkmate
so instead when you move the Queen
trying to hold on to both this fish up
I'm sorry I didn't mean to do that
trying to hold on to both this bishop
and the square so Queen is quite a bit
overloaded here and not what can black
do how does black finish it off now
okay
Queen to d1 and now if I play Queen
takes D off flat if I play Queen takes D
Wan what do you do me and if I play
Queen III you also have rook F lon
you know just winning all the pieces
another way to win here similar concept
queenie for alright yeah alright
good so the thing about themes is that
once you look at a lot of a lot of
problems in one theme they start to
become much easier right there's one
more I wanted to show you yeah this
position so it's like the first one is
harder but then you keep looking at the
theme and it becomes very easy and
that's that's why you study tactics so
that themes that would be difficult if
you saw them for the first time will
become quite quickly for you and that's
called pattern recognition and it's
really important it's hard to become a
strong player if you haven't put in a
lot of hours studying those tactics
doing those drills and we've discussed
it before you can use books and a
combination of books and computer
training but you got to do something
this one's a white move just wait to
move in line
we're gonna after you on okay Z yeah
yeah and this is just I just get put
this one in because everything else we
looked at was quite flashy and this
one's more of a quiet move which is
absolutely winning you're just attacking
yet too many times there's no way for
them to get the rook to defend this
square another time right so sometimes
if your opponent's back rank is weakened
off even if they see the threat you know
there's nothing they can do about it
right this work can't come back this
work is pinned so we can't go to e7 and
this work is unable to come back to the
background and that's why a lot of times
you don't see people even though I think
yesterday I showed you guys an example
over over rook up and over which is
often a way to get the rook into the
attack a lot of times you see people
keeping the rooks on the back rank for
at least a while because it's important
to have some protection there Queen
where I'm in this position Queen c8 you
can take it maybe you were thinking a
Queen c7 but yet Queen c7 if Queen takes
c7 rookie eight would be a good idea but
instead of playing Queen take c7 you
removed the pin now so you can't get in
to stick with a rock right I've been
showing so many sacrifices I can see why
you were just immediately gravitate
towards looking in a sack but anyway I'm
so yeah this uh this is just a this
lecture focusing on on background check
mate should be a reminder to you to just
keep doing those tactics so that this
kind of stuff comes quicker to you than
ever and a lot of tactics books won't
tell you what the theme is but
eventually there are only so many
different themes in chess and you'll
start to see similar patterns